Ich bin 73 Jahre alt. Am 14. April 1952. Und wie groß sind Sie zurzeit? 1,78 m. Wie viel wiegen Sie? 86 Kilo.
Herr Bockermann, wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin? Das ist Herr Doktor Müller.
Herr Doktor Müller. Vielen Dank, Herr Bockermann. Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich habe seit gestern ziemlich starke Schmerzen im Bauch. Mehr im oberen Bauch. Und die strahlen auch in den Rücken aus.
Sind diese Beschwerden rechtsseitig oder linksseitig?
Die Schmerzen sind mehr in der Mitte und mehr links.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen in den Ganzrücken?
Nein, auf der Höhe, wo ich die Bauchschmerzen habe, sind die Schmerzen auch hinten im Rücken.
Könnten wir sagen oder beschreiben, wie guttelt für mich?
Ja, kann man sagen, göttelförmig.
Okay. Alles klar. Herr Bockermann, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben auf einer Schmerzskala von 0 bis 10, wo 1 und keine Schmerzen bedeutet und 10 die stärksten Schmerzen?
7 bis 8.
Und können Sie diese Beschwerden schmerzen aushalten oder brauchen Sie ein Schmerzmittel?
Noch kann ich sie aushalten. Wenn es jetzt nicht so lange dauert, kann ich sie aushalten.
Ja, es dauert ungefähr 15, 20 Minuten.
Das kann ich aushalten.
Okay, super.
Haben Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht.
Bis jetzt nicht.
Was versteckt oder verlinnt hat Ihre Schmerzen, Herr Bockermann?
Also bewegen ist nicht gut.
Ich bleibe lieber liegen auf dem Rücken und ziehe die Beine etwas an, die Knie stelle ich etwas an.
Das ist noch mit am besten.
Okay.
Das ist klar.
Wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben als brennende Schmerz, brennend oder dumpf?
Das sind mehr dumpf und bohrend.
Okay, dumpf und bohrend.
Haben Sie begleitende Symptome wie Übelkeit, Erbruch, Erbrechen?
Ja, mir ist übel ziemlich stark und ich habe bisher auch zweimal erbrochen.
Okay.
Wann war das?
Ja, das eine war vielleicht vor 10 Stunden oder so und das andere war vor 2 Stunden.
Okay, und vor 2 Stunden.
Und wie sah Ihre Erbrochen aus?
Das war ja schleimig-gelblich.
Schleimig-gelblich.
Gibt es keine Blutung oder?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, okay.
Sind Sie diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal?
Ja, so stark.
Ich hatte vor einem halben Jahr mal auch 2 Tage Bauchschmerzen.
Die waren auch ziemlich stark, aber nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Die gingen nicht ähnlich, ähnlich.
Die gingen nach 2 Tagen aber wieder weg.
Aber jetzt sind sie deutlich stärker und das macht mir Sorgen.
Okay, ich verstehe, dass das für Sie sehr unangenehm ist.
Herr Bekremann, 2 Tage haben Sie, hatten Sie diese Schmerzen damals?
Ja.
Und selbst gegangen sind diese Beschwerden.
Wann war das genau?
Da war ich empfehlt.
Das war vor einem halben Jahr.
Das war im August vielleicht.
Juli, August letzten Jahres.
Okay.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden haben Sie andere Arztbesuche?
Nein, ich war da im Urlaub in Österreich.
Das ging nach 2 Tagen wieder besser.
Dann bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Bekremann?
Ja, ich habe Fieber gemessen.
Vorhin hatte ich 38,3.
Ich fühle mich auch so etwas heiß an.
Ich habe auch stark geschwitzt.
Auch seit gestern Abend?
Ja, im Laufe der letzten Nacht.
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Ich fühle mich ernähre.
Ich esse gerne Fleisch.
Okay.
Meine Frau sagt immer, ich soll mehr Obst und Gemüse essen.
Aber das mag ich nicht.
Ich habe auch viel Fleisch.
Ich esse lieber Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Trinken Sie viel Alkohol oder Kaffee?
Alkohol trinke ich schon regelmäßig.
2-3 Flaschen Bier pro Tag trinke ich.
Und auch mal 1-2 Schnäpfe.
Ein bis 2 Schnäpfe.
Und Kaffee?
Ja, ich trinke immer.
Ich trinke immer.
Und Kaffee?
Morgen trinke ich 2.000 Kaffee.
2.000? Okay.
Leiten Sie unter Belegungen?
Belegungen?
Oder haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Sie ein Hochkommande von Mageninheit haben?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt bisher.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder enge Gefühle?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Herr Böckermann, ist Ihnen aufgefallen,
dass Sie in der Netzteilzeit in Ihrem Bau
Vorfüllung geschwellen haben?
Oder gelbliche Farbeveränderungen in Ihrer Körper?
Ganz in Ihrer Körper?
Ja, ganz in Ihrer Körper.
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Plankenbereich
oder Umgebung Ihrer Nabel
Farbeveränderungen, wie Bläuliche
oder Brauma?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Herr Böckermann, jetzt werde ich einige Fragen
in der gemeinsamen medizinischen Situation zustande stellen.
Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie seit gestern Abend
Fieber haben
und Froschitz schützen.
Haben Sie auch Nachtschweiß?
Ich habe in der letzten Nacht,
in der letzten Nacht habe ich auch stärker geschwitzt.
Ja, sonst schwitze ich nicht nachts.
Okay.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit oder Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert?
Nein, Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Appetit, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich esse gerne Fleisch und Kartoffeln.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ich meine nicht gestern, sondern vorher.
Der ist ganz gut.
Ich habe es schon lange, aber ich kann normalerweise wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay, normalerweise gut.
Außer diese Wasserlastenprobleme
haben Sie andere Probleme in Ihrer Urin?
Zum Beispiel brennende Schmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber jetzt seit gestern habe ich keinen Stuhlgang.
Normalerweise regelmäßig jeden Tag.
Haben Sie Ihre Ernährungsgewohnheiten
verändert in den letzten Wochen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, immer gleich, oder?
Immer gleich.
Okay.
Herr Buchmann, leiten Sie unter Husten
Atemnot, Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Atemnot, Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Mein Arzt sagt immer, ich habe eine chronische Bronchitis.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich solange schon rauche.
Ich muss morgens häufiger so abhusten.
Wenn ich aufgestanden bin, dann habe ich längere Zeit Husten.
Da kommt auch manchmal Schleim raus.
Das ist im Winter schlimmer als im Sommer.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie chronische Bronchitis?
Ich würde sagen mindestens 5-6 Jahre.
Mindestens 5-6 Jahre.
Wurde bei Ihnen COPD Diagnose festgestellt?
Wissen Sie?
Es war einmal bei einem Lungenfacharzt.
Er hat so etwas gesagt.
Er sagt, er kommt vom Rauchen.
Okay.
Sie leiten unter keine Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Herzstolpern habe ich nicht.
Ich habe nur hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe schon seit 10-15 Jahren einen Blutdruck.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Stress?
Als Blüher mehr Stress?
Nein, ich habe keinen Stress.
Ich bin in Rente schon seit fast 10 Jahren.
Wenn ich in Rente bin, dann habe ich noch keinen Stress.
Herr Popkermann, trainieren Sie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich trainiere.
Ich gehe zwischendurch mal etwas spazieren.
Aber das ist nicht weit.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Rulogie regelmäßig?
Nein, ich habe keine Rulogie.
Ich habe keine Rulogie.
Umdrehen Sie Ihre Rulogie regelmäßig?
Nein, keine Rulogie.
Es war vor 2 Jahren ».
Ich gehe in Rente zu Hause.
Ich brauche VIDAR-Beräftigkeiten.
Ich hatte einige Fragen.
Herr Popkermann, RA Hunt?
Rauchen Sie? Ja, ich rauche ungefähr seit 30 Jahren, 35 Jahren rauche ich so eine
Stachel pro Tag. Haben Sie schon einmal versucht mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören? Nein.
Oder Alkohol? Nein, das wollen viele, meine Kinder wollen das immer und meine Freunde,
die sagen auch, hör auf zu rauchen, aber nee, ich will das nicht. Ah, okay, Sie wollen das nicht.
Ja, wenn Sie wollen und Sie sollten, Sie müssen eigentlich mit dem Rauchen und
Alkohol aufzuhören und ich würde Ihnen gerne helfen. Ja, aber jetzt habe ich erst mal
diese starken Schmerzen. Ja, okay, Sie haben recht, okay. Nehmen Sie Drogen? Nein.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten, Herr Bokeman? Nein. Nein. Ja, Sie haben mir gesagt,
dass Sie an einem chronische Bronchitis leiden, seit fünf, sechs Jahren und an einem
Arterie-Landhypertonie leiden, seit zehn, 15 Jahren, richtig? Ja, und ich habe auch noch
zwei Gichtanfälle gehabt. Okay. Diese Harnsäure ist erhöht und da muss ich auch ein Medikament
nehmen. Okay, wann war das? Die Gichtanfälle waren so vor drei Jahren und vor vier Jahren,
glaube ich. Vor drei, vor vier Jahren. Gibt es weitere Grundschalkrankungen, Herr Bokeman?
Nein. Nein. Nein. Wurden Sie sich schon einmal operiert? Ja, als Kind wurde ich am
Leistenbruch operiert. Da war ich, glaube ich, elf Jahre alt auf der rechten Seite.
Mit den Leistenbruch? Ja, rechts. Und dann hatte ich noch mal eine Operation, da
habe ich meinen linker Unterarm gebrochen. Da war ich so, wie alt war ich da vielleicht,
da habe ich Sport gemacht, da habe ich Fußball gespielt. Da war ich vielleicht 19, 20
und da war der Unterarm gebrochen, der musste operiert werden. 19, 20, ungefähr
Jahre alt. Gibt es weitere Operationen? Nein. Okay. Waren diese Operationen
komplikationslos? Ja, so weit ich weiß, ja. Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein,
Herr Bokeman? Also ich nehme einmal für die Hansäure, diese Hansäureerhöhung, da nehme
ich ein Mittel ein, Moment, das heißt, alo purinol. Wie viel Milligramm und wie oft
nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein? Also davon nehme ich eine am Tag und dahinter steht 300. 300.
300. Okay. Und dann nehme ich noch eine, die eine Tablette, die habe ich nicht vertragen,
da habe ich stärkeren Husten vorgekriegt für den Blutdruck, die wurde gestellt und jetzt
nehme ich seit ungefähr zwei Jahren das Mittel heißt Kandesatan, da ist der Husten nicht
stärker geworden mit der Tablette, kann die Satan, acht steht dahinter, da nehme ich eine
morgens und eine abends. Eine abends, alles klar und gibt es weitere Medikamente? Nein. Zum Beispiel
für die fronche Branche, das haben sich sprengen. Nehm ich nichts, da wurde diskutiert, ob ich da so
ein Spreh nehmen soll und aber ich habe irgendwas gegen Medikamente und da hat der Hausarzt gesagt,
dann wollen wir erstmal gar nichts machen, weil er glaubt, ich bin da nicht so zuverlässig.
Okay. Herr Bockermann, gibt es in Ihrer Familie Kronchealkankungen? Ja, mein Vater, der ist
verstorben an Lungenkrebs. Er ist mir sehr leid. Er war 86 Jahre alt. Er hatte auch hohen Blutdruck
und die Mutter, die ist verstorben, im Alter von 85, sie hatte einen Sturz im Haus, ist die Treppe
runtergestürzt und hatte ein Blutung im Kopf, im Gehirn und sie hatte da auch einen Oberschenkelbruch
und an den Folgen ist sie dann verstorben. Mein herzlicher und beileiter Herr Bockermann. Ich habe
auch einen Bruder, er ist 70 Jahre alt, der wurde vor zwei Jahren am Darmkrebs operiert. Wie ist
ihr gesund? Geht es eigentlich ganz gut. Sie sind Rentner und was waren Sie von Beruf?
Ich war von Beruf Elektriker. Leben Sie allein Herr Bockermann oder haben Sie einen Vernehmigung?
Ja, inzwischen bin ich seit ungefähr zwölf Jahren von meiner Frau geschieden.
Und leben Sie allein? Sind Sie proch ständig geimpft?
Ja, wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe, dann macht er gerade im Herbst immer eine Impfung gegen
Grippe und gegen Corona, das habe ich jetzt im November bekommen. Ansonsten schaut er immer
so, was so notwendig ist. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Ja, aber nicht so wesentlich. Ich war mal in Österreich und mal an der Ostsee, aber sonst
keine weiteren Reisen, keine Fernreisen. Okay, wann waren diese Reisungen? Österreich war ich vor
einem halben Jahr. Im August, als ich diese Bauchschmerzen hatte, war ich in Österreich und
im Oktober war ich noch mal eine Woche an der Ostsee. Ja, Herr Bockermann, jetzt möchte ich
kurz zusammenfassen. Wenn ich etwas falsch sage, könnt ihr mich bitte korrigieren. Seit gestern Abend oder Morgen?
Seit gestern Morgen. Seit gestern Morgen haben Sie starke Bauchschmerzen im Oberanbau, aber
linksseitig, mittiger und linksseitig. Mitte und links, ja. Mitte und links, Mitte und links.
Sie beschreiben Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala mit sieben bis acht Konzenen und Ihre Schmerzen
strahlen in den Rücken. Bei Bewegung verschlimmen sich die Schmerzen und Sie beschreiben auch
diese Schmerzen als dumpf und bohrend. Außerdem haben Sie seit gestern Übelkeit und haben
Sie zweimal erbrochen, einmal vor ungefähr zehn Stunden, einmal vor zwei Stunden und diese
Erbrochene sah schleimlich ungeblich aus. Richtig verstanden, oder? Ja. Okay. Normalerweise gehen
Sie zur Zollethe regelmäßig für den Stull, aber seit gestern haben Sie keinen Stull. Ja. Okay.
Ja, möchtern Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen an mich? Nein, Hauptsache mir wird bald geholfen.
Ja, ich werde gerne Ihnen helfen, Herr Bockermann. Jetzt werde ich Sie körpfeilig untersuchen,
Ihre Vizapparameter messen und Blut abnehmen. Danach brauchen wir einige operativ diagnostische
Methoden, um die genaue Diagnose stellen zu können. Wenn wir alle Ergebnisse zusammen
getragen haben, werden wir miteinander noch einmal sprechen. Okay, das können wir so machen.
Okay, legen Sie sich hin bitte. Ich komme gleich zur Unterung. Alles klar. Gut, danke. Dann haben
Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, umzuschreiben, die Patientensprache in Fachbegriffe. Okay. Die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die heute Abend hier dabei sind, haben vielleicht noch Fragen. Ich habe
eine Frage. Ja. Herr Bockermann, gibt es irgendwelche Ausstöße für diese Schmessen, zum Beispiel
haben Sie vielleicht vorgestern viel Alkohol getrunken oder nach dem Fatiga es speisen?
Ja, vorgestern habe ich, da war ich beim Nachbarn, der hatte Geburtstag, da habe ich vielleicht ein,
zwei Schnäppze mehr getrunken. Das kann sein. Danke schön. Okay. Der Schmerz ist immer da.
Manchmal wird er etwas schlimmer. Manchmal kommt so eine Welle, aber das ist nicht sehr oft,
aber ich habe immer, der Schmerz ist immer da, nie weg. Würde bei Ihnen Magandam-Spiegelung
irgendwann durchgeführt? Nein. Danke schön. Die Schmerz, und hatte ich ja vor einem halben
Jahr mal, da waren sie aber nicht so stark und das dauerte nur zwei Tage und das war im Urlaub
in Österreich und danach bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen, aber eine Magandam-Spiegelung wurde
noch nie gemacht. Danke schön. Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt. Hallo. Ich habe heute einen neuen
Patientin aufgenommen, habe sehr kurz Zeit dafür. Ja. Es handelt sich um Paul Bockermann,
einer 73-jährigen Patientin. Er stellte sich heute wegen, seit gestern, morgen bestehender,
Abdominalgie bei uns vor. Er beschrieb die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala mit sieben bis acht
von zehn und als duft und bohrend. Bis jetzt hat er keine, oder seine, sein Hausarzt oder andere
Arzt nicht besucht, zum ersten Mal zu uns gekommen ist und zuerst ist er zu uns gekommen.
Ich traue seine Schmerzen, ich traue ihnen den Rücken wie Gürtel für mich, die Abdominalgie stehen,
besonders in der Mitte und mehr linksseitig. Im gesamten Bauch oder mehr im Unter- oder Oberbauch?
Oberbauch. Er hat gesagt, ja. Okay, ich fasse einmal kurz zusammen. Der 73-jährige Patient,
Herr Bockermann, berichtet über starke Abdominalschmerzen überwiegend im Epigastrium links mit
Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal. Mit Ausstrahlung nach Dorsal. Ich bitte nicht in den Rücken sagen,
möglichst nach Dorsal. Und der Schmerz wird als duft und bohrend beschrieben auf der Schmerzkala
zwischen 7 und 8. Ja, genau. Okay, gut. Ja. Okay, er hat dagegen keine Medikamente
eingenommen. Wenn er, nein, bei Bewegung hat er diese Schmerzen schlechter gefühlt und wenn er seine
Knie beugen, zum Mitte beugen, hat er sich besser, oder diese Beschwerden besser, ist diese Schmerzen
besser geworden. Ja, Sie können auch sagen, diese Schmerzen verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung. Ja,
verschlimmern sich bei Bewegung und bessern sich bei Rückenlage mit angewinkelten Kniehen. Also
angeschnitten in den Rückenlage, wo ich sage. Okay, danke. Hat der Patient diese Schmerzen schon
mal gehabt? Vor einem halben Jahr, als er nach Österreich gegangen ist, hat er zwei Tage solche
Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark und diese Beschwerden sind selbst gegangen, deswegen hat er keinen
Besuch, keinen Arzt besucht. Okay, gut. Fragen nach, Entschuldigung, zuerst möchte ich sagen, dass er
außer dem Nausea und Emesis hat und seit gestern hat er zweimal erbrochen. Einmal war es vor zehn
Stunden und einmal war es vor zwei Stunden und seine Erbrochene sah schleimig und gelblich aus.
Okay, gut. Außer dem hat sie seit gestern Abend Febrikes gefühlt und er hat es einmal gemessen.
Er war der Körpertemperatur, war 38,3 Grad. Außer dem hat er Schütterfrost und ja nächtliche
Hyperhydrose. Ich habe gefragt, wie er sich ernährt und er ernährt sich normalerweise viel Fleisch und
Kartoffeln. Außer dem trinkt er viel Bier und Schnäppse, zwei bis drei Flasche biatäglich und
auch Schnäppse zwei bis drei zweimal, ein bis zwei Mal. Entschuldigung. Wir können dazu sagen,
sagen Sie ruhig dazu, es besteht ein erheblicher, ja ein erheblicher Alkoholkonsum. Erheblicher.
Erheblich heißt ja, also schon er deutlich erhöht. Alkoholkonsum von zwei bis drei Flaschen
Bier pro Tag und zwei bis drei Schnäppsen pro Tag. Das ist schon ein erhebliches Maß zu viel Alkohol.
Okay, ich verstehe, gut. Vorgestern ist er eine Einladung gegangen und er hat viel
getrunken als vorher. Eins bis zwei Schnäppsen. Schnäppse, ja. Mehr Schnäppsen, genau.
Wozu Frage noch zu den allgemeinen Zeichen hat der Patient Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen und beim Stuhlgang?
Ja, Wasserlassen. Hat er normalerweise täglich zweimal Wasserlassen, besonders in der Nacht.
Kennen Sie da den Fachbegriff für nächtliches Wasserlassen? Genau, Nekturis.
Und normalerweise sein Stuhlgewohnheit ist sehr regelmäßig, aber seit gestern hat er keinen Stuhl mehr.
Passierend hat normalerweise täglich Stuhlgang, aber seit gestern nicht mehr.
Seit gestern nicht mehr, okay. Ihr Appetit oder Gewicht hat sich in letzter Zeit nicht verwendet.
Er leidet an einem chronische Bronchitis seit fünf bis sechs Monaten. Deswegen hat er es im Winter
schlimmer geworden. Man kann sagen, er hat morgens einen produktiven Husten.
Produktiven Husten. Also mit Expektoranz. Genau. Und er rauft regelmäßig Einschachter pro Tag
seit 35 Jahren und Drogenkonsum wurden verneins. Sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht ein
Nikotin ab Usus von 35 Packageiers. Okay. Eine Packung pro Tag, 35 Jahre kann man sagen.
Genau, das ist einfach. Bei ihm ist keine Allergie, unsere Verträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er leidet außerdem an einer arteriellen Hypertonie seit 10 bis 15 Jahren.
Außerdem hat er zwei Mal Arctitis urica. Sehr gut, ja. Vor drei Jahren und vor vier Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt er regelmäßig täglich 300 mg Aluptoyol und er leidet an ein, ja,
der Arcterie-Hyperton habe ich schon gesagt. Und deswegen hat er seit zwei Jahren regelmäßig
kann der Sartan 8 mg morgens und abends ein. Bei ihm wurde mit 11 Jahren, ja, eine Operation
durchgeführt in Guinalherni. Ja, in Guinalherni Operation im rechten Zeit durchgeführt und wegen
einer Fraktur, welche Fraktur, unser Arm Fraktur, Radius oder Urla, in linken Arm eine Operation
durchgeführt im Jahr von 19 oder 20. Ja, im Alter von 19. Im Alter von genau. Okay, das waren die
Operationen, ja, gut. Genau, ja. Und gibt es Erkrankungen in der Familie? Ja, seine beide Eltern
sind verstorben. Sein Vater hat einen lungen Bruchatkarzinom erlitten und mit 68 Jahren ist er verstorben.
Seine Mutter war 85 Jahre und er hatte einen Unfall. Zu Hause ist sie gestürzt oder gestürzt.
Eine Treppe, eine Treppe gestürzt, ja, genau. Und Gehirnblutung hatte sie damals. Der Patient hat gesagt, sie
hatte eine Gehirnblutung. Sie können ruhig sagen Schädelhirntrauma. Wir wissen ja nicht, genau.
Sagen Sie ruhig, die Mutter erlitt einen Schädelhirntrauma und was noch, was noch für eine
Verletzung ist? Und noch ob das eine Femur Fraktur hatte. Gut, und daran ist die Mutter verstorben. Genau.
An diesem Unfallfolgen ist die Mutter verstorben. Okay, gibt es Geschwister? Ja, er hat ein Bruder,
er ist 70 Jahre alt vor zwei Jahren, hat er einen Kolonkarzinom erlitten und er wurde operiert und er ist
jetzt gut. Ja, es geht ihm ganz gut. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtstiagnose? Die Beschwerden sprechen
für eine Pankreatitis. Differenzial diagnostisch kommen eine akute Holististitis und Gastroenteritis in
Betracht. Um meine Verdachtstiagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich den Patienten zunächst körperlich
untersuchen. Natürlich zunächst Vitalparameter messen, Blut abnehmen, EKG schreiben,
um mögliche Herzerkrankungen auszuschließen. Danach werde ich ihn körperlich untersuchen.
Im Blut werde ich amylase, oder Cross-Hes-Bluet-Bills, CRP, BSG-Werte, Troponin-CK, TKMB, amylase,
lipase, biliribin, alp, AST, GGT, Werte. Gut, vielen Dank. Das beherrschen Sie perfekt. Vielen Dank. Das
können Sie. Die Verdachtstiagnose kann ich teilen. Eventuell ist es ja so, dass es schon der zweite
Schub einer Pankreatitis ist. Vor einem halben Jahr hatte der Patient auch ähnliche epigastrische
und dorsale Schmerzen nicht ganz so stark. Man kann eventuell davon ausgehen, dass er da schon
mal einen Pankreatitis-Schub hatte. Und jetzt ist es schlimmer, heftiger, stärker. Es bricht
einiges dafür. Der Patient hat einen erheblichen Alkoholkonsum. Vor zwei Tagen hatte er wahrscheinlich
noch mehr Schnaps getrunken bei der Beier. Das spricht alles ein bisschen dafür. Und die
Differenzialdiagose kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Man muss eventuell reflektorisch denken,
dass er vielleicht einen Subelius hat. Kein Stuhlgang seit gestern. Das ist aber oft
reflektorisch der Ilius ja aufgrund der Schmerzen, der Abdominalschmerzen. Aber auch das muss
sicherlich gut abgeklärt werden, nicht, dass der Patient auch noch einen Ilius entwickelt zu der
Pankreatitis. Gut. Aber ich denke, Sie haben das ja gut gemacht, worauf Sie achten müssen. Ich
habe Sie sehr gut verstanden. Worauf Sie achten müssen, ist, dass Sie die Zeit einhalten.
Sie haben vielleicht den Gong gehört nach 20 Minuten. Da kam eine Musik, da ist oben so eingestellt.
Sie waren am Ende bei 24 Minuten für die Anamnese. Und ich glaube, Sie haben in der Prüfung 20
Minuten Zeit. So wird mir das zumindest berichtet. Da achten Sie bitte ein bisschen drauf,
dass Sie in dem Zeitrahmen bleiben. Sonst kann es passieren, dass vielleicht dann gesagt wird,
so jetzt ist 20 Minuten. Jetzt können Sie nicht weiterfragen. Jetzt ist die Anamnese zu Ende, dass Sie
da versuchen, die Zeit gut einzuhalten, das Zeitmanagement zu optimieren. Also ich habe Sie
sprachlich sehr gut verstanden. Sie haben auch, denke ich, gute Fragen gestellt und Sie können
auch die Fachbegriffe gut. In der Prüfung haben Sie etwas mehr Zeit, sich die Begriffe
wie nächtliches Wasser lassen, dass Sie das gleich markieren und dann übersetzen Nüktorie.
Die Leistenhernie können Sie eventuell noch sagen, im Alter von elf Jahren erfolgte eine
Herneotomie. Herneotomie, genau. Wegen Leistenhernie rechts oder Ingrinalhernie rechts. Das wäre
dann perfekt. Aber es ist nicht zwingend notwendig. Aber Sie haben das gut, guten Fachsprache,
haben Sie gut eingesetzt. Gut. Ja, also ich sehe Ihre Prüfung über morgen, würde ich jetzt sagen,
können Sie so gelassen entgegen sehen, wie es geht. Es ist immer Stress, aber Sie sind,
glaube ich, gut vorbereitet.